*musique rap*
Ça va ou quoi?
Comment allez-vous ? Moi ça va extrêmement bien à part qu'il est 10h du matin
et que j'ai la voix du matin comme si il était 6h,  c'est un problème de Youtubeur
*rire*, quelle insolence ! Aujourd'hui on va jouer à
un jeu vidéo, qui est tout simplement excellent, que j'apprécie grandement
Il s'appelle CUPHEAD, vous avez tous déjà entendu parler de ce jeu parce que
plein de médias en ont parlé en disant qu'il était incroyable, à juste titre ! Ou alors vous avez vu le fameux
gameplay du journaliste qui reste coincé dans le tuto pendant je sais pas combien de minutes
*Musique triste*
(Ne vous moquer pas j'étais comme lui)
*moi dans cuphead*
Oooh, c'était horrible, ce moment était tellement terrible
Petit brief rapide, c'est un jeu de plateforme
qui s'inspire des dessins animés des années 30 donc c'est extrêmement cool, c'est une ambiance que l'on adore
Vous avez tous vu des extraits du premier épisode de Mickey jamais créé, bah c'est dans ce délire là
Et on va pas se mytho, c'est un jeu ou il faut un peu de skill, même beaucoup de skill
Il est un peu dur, un peu rageant !
Bref j'ai lancé le jeu la dernière fois en live parce que j'avais envie d'y jouer, tout le monde en parlait et je me disais putain ! ça doit comme même être ouf !
Et bin c'est ouf et aujourd'hui j'fais une vidéo dessus
parce que mon pote je suis qu'à 35% du jeu
Il nous reste des boss à faire, alors on va y aller tout de suite ! Ooh juste l'intro m'a donné chaud !
Mec j'imagine pas quand j'vais commencer à jouer et à rager bien sévère! Allez
La musique c'est aussi basé sur les années 30, c'est du bon jazz bien cool
Et alors faut savoir qu'il y a deux types de niveau : il y a les niveaux où c'est un boss, il y a plusieurs phases c'est-à-dire qu'il va falloir analyser
ses mouvements, s'adapter en fonction et ce à chaque nouvelles phases
Okay et donc là on a un niveau où c'est pas un boss, c'est un niveau normal
on va s'mettre en regular je ne mettrai pas la difficulté en simple. Je vais faire la vraie difficulté
parce qu'on est des bonhommes ! C'est bien ça fait un moment que j'ai pas joué, ça va me remettre dans le bain. OOH C'EST UN BOSS !
J'me suis trompé (x2)
*HAAA* Okay faut que je saute sur les nuages et faut que j'esquive *HAAA* mais mec c'est ma première game
Mais quelle idééée ! Vous voyez j'fais des gaffes, qu'est ce qu'il fait ?
Ha c'est nouveau ça ! Vous voyez, il envoie différents sorts et quand tu découvres le sort pour la première fois
*Haaa* j'avais pas vu la queue ! Donc ici, à chaque petit piquet qui précède le drapeau
ça signifie que c'est une nouvelle phase donc que le boss peut utiliser une nouvelle compétence
pour nous démolir la gueule ! *HOOO* j'ai chaud ! jvais finir la vidéo à poil !
Alors ! Donc là on a vu qu'il envoie une boule et des anneaux, c'est la phase la plus simple de l'histoire du jeu.
Et ensuite il envoie une boule. Là il y a la boule
Il y a la queue en bas, ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Faut faire attention à deux choses en même temps c'est ça qui est dur et en plus il faut que je vous parle en même temps !
Waaah deux boules ! Putain il imite les hommes c'est incroyable ! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Enorme blague de beauf bien sûr abonnez vous :)
*RIP*
Ah ! J'ai oublié un détail important ! On a 3 vies par niveau entier !
Donc là on a nos 3 vies, logiquement pour survivre il faut qu'on atteigne la dernière phase
Avec 2 vies minimum ! Voilà, c'est un peu la règle d'or
HAAAAAAA je me suis fait AVOOIIIIRRRRR ! C'est bon !
OK, OK, nouvelle phase ! Oh putain c'est quoi ça ? Ils vont faire quoi eux ? Ils vont faire de la merde ? HAAAAAA !
Y'en a un qui saute de manière aléatoire à chaque fois ! OOOOH PUTAIN !!
OK, on a analysé, on va y arriver vous en faites pas hein ?
Oh putain !
Première phase passée il nous reste 2 vies
Faut que je fasse gaffe
OK je l'ai vu !
Il n'y a que très peu de temps pour réagir !
On va perdre j'vous annonce hein ! J'aimerais bien voir la phase d'après !
Il attend que je saute pour sauter c'est incroyable !
*Jeu qui dit* You're UP !
La queue ! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) Whoooooooooa
Ok c'est bon ! Dernière phase !
Whoa il a trois têtes !!
AAAAAAAAAAH
Raté
Oh mais je suis pris entre la boule et la queue quoi  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)! On dirait un film porno quoi ! Nan mais vraiment .....
Il anticipe mon saut mec ! C'est normal ça ??? (oui)
Oh j'ai envie de manger ma main !
*mange sa main*
C'est bon
Oh on a deux vies pour la troisième phase !!!!!!!
La troisième phase elle est scandaleuse...
Waaaa il lance des flammes ! Mais pour un dragon ça me paraît plutô... OOOOOOOh
Oh il relance des flammes aussitôt !
Nan mais mec c'est chaud !!
*frappe sa chaise*
Ca fait super mal. J'ai changé de chaise, l'accoudoir est très fin je me suis baisé ! NAAN !
Mais le mec saute dans le vide mais quel connard !
*Rage*
Rholala
*tryhard*
OK cette fois je vais utiliser mon pouvoir pour cette phase,  regardez bien. Et c'est partiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiii
Oh mais mec !!
*Rage* (Frappe quelque chose)
Tout va bien ! J'arrive pas à prévoir quand les flammes sautent !
Ah si ! Elle fait une petite animation avant de sauter je suis con !
Elle va sauter la pute mais ça ne m'a pas empêché de me la prendre
*utilise son pouvoir* IEUUUUUUUUUUU !!!!
(voix digne d'un opéra)
YOU DIED!     (R.I.P.)
C'est le rush c'est maintenant
*plus de tryhard*
Oh Fils de p**e, je l'avais pas vu
Oh fils de p***
Meurs meurs meurs meurs meuuurs !
DEMOOON !!!
Ah c'est ta botte secrète ça hein ? Ha il sait bien comment le lancer sans me prévenir
J'ai regardé, il n'y a RIEN qui l'indique !
NOPE
OK, vous savez ce qu'on va faire maintenant ? On va changer de pouvoir et mettre celui-là,
c'est une sorte de fusil à pompe. Et maintenant, on va passer ce niveau en musique
*Musique épique chanté par Squeezie*
AAAAAAAAH !!!
*Halètements*
*Soupire*
Aaaaah...
Je crois que je pleure vraiment de joie là ! Haaa...
Pour moi, c'est ça le jeu vidéo, c'est quand c'est super dur mais que tu réussis, t'as un sentiment
T'es vraiment heureux quoi. Vas-y je suis dans un état psychologique de détresse, je me confie
Il faut savoir qu'à 12h30, je dois manger avec mon père,
Mais j'étais bloqué sur ce boss
Donc j'étais en train de culpabiliser vis-à-vis de mon papa
En me disant "Je vais être en retard !"
Oh PUTAIIIN !!!
YESSS !!!
Oh on l'a eu en plus on a eu B-
On a eu une super note mec !
J'veux qu'on moule ma tête dans du bronze
et qu'on la foute à l'aéroport Charles de Gaulle.
Comme Ronaldo.
Allez s'il vous plaît !
Alors alors...
Musée 2
Alors je vous explique ce que c'est :
C'est une jarre et il faut aider la personne qui est dedans en la protégeant des fantômes, donc il faut tuer tous les fantômes.
Et j'ai oublié de le dire mais tout ce qui est rose dans le jeu en fait ça se tue en sautant et en les claquant,
voilà !
NOOOONN !!! Ok put***
Ils sont durs
Faut que je leur claque les fesses
YES ! La double
Oh la la mais là on est chaud, hein.
Oh la la mais tellement aisément !
Et là du coup on a sauvé la personne qui était dans la jarre
et qui fallait protéger.
Et qui est-ce ?
Une jolie demoiseeeelle !
C'est une coupe... Ah ! On a débloqué un nouveau super-pouvoir !
C'est quoi ? Invincibility, tu deviens invincible pour une courte période.
Mais je suis trop con mec, c'est ce pouvoir là qu'il fallait utiliser sur le dragon
Pour la dernière phase
C'est pour ça que j'ai galéré
Je me disais que c'était risqué ce que je faisais je risquais de...
Tomber dans vide, après l'avoir fait.
Oh le con !
Alors alors
On va finir cette zone ensemble, hein moi je vous le dit
Oh mais c'est un petit niveau pépère, mec
Nous ce qu'on veut voir c'est des boss
Ces niveaux pépères on les fait pépouse
Ha il est super dur celui-là !
il y a une histoire de gravité mon pote
regarde ça et  voilà et les voitures elles me démontent
on va y arriver, on va y arriver
c'est pas hyper dur
HA, ok ça marche
ohohohohohoh, je comprend pas !
j'ai rien compris
En fait ce qui est horrible c'est que quand t'appuies sur le bouton
ça change pas immédiatement la gravité...vous voyiez il y a un petit temps
Sale piège en fait
UNE PIÈCE !!!!
de la tune !!!!
haaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa
Alors ça c'est quoi? Faut tirer je crois !
ouchhhhhh
NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOON
Quelle erreure!
je vais pas vous mentir, c'est assez dur de jouer à l'envers
hooooo !!!! je suis mort
oh puta*n
stop !!!! Tabarnak
je sais ce qu'il faut que je fasse: faut que je change d'armes
puta*n en une heure j'ai fait qu'un boss mec
Autant dire que le durée de vie de ce jeu est assez ouf
IL EST MORT, il est dead
Allez on lui passe dans la bouche
Suivant
Oh puta*n c'est quoi ça
oh c'est quoi ça?
C'est parti speed run sans jamais s'arrêter, c'est la technique
oh je l'ai pas vu
je comprend pas, c'est...c'est une nouvelle partie de niveau que j'ai pas encore faite
ha ouias d'acord
ok j'ai compris fallait que je passe quand il cri
NAN ! dernière ligne droite,si on perd maintenant je chiale
je fais quoi? faut juste que je passe
Pas d'arnaque s'il vous plait
attend je crois avoir compris
VOILA ! ON EST BIEN
bon qu'est ce qu'il nous reste à faire là?
Et voila le dernier niveau que je n'ai pas fait et on  est bon
* musique du jeu derrière* Ho c'est un boss
Oh puta*n
Alos c'est quoi ce boss, qu'est ce qu'il fait?
OK, il envoie des bonbons
Ha c'est que des bonbons...HA!
OK, un certain moove à avoir
OK c'est ça, faut que je fasse ce que je fais là
ok...( x4)
Et une fois que je l'ai eu, analysons les phases
ha, elle est rageuse, je lui ai pété son bonbon
Tu vas me faire quoi? Tu vas faire quoi le ptit gars?
qu'est ce qu'il y a
* rire* Ok
oh j'ai fait de la merde
La map à l'air assez serrée, je ferais mieux de prendre l'arme fusil à pompe
WHAT !!!!!! Mais ça a changé, c'est pas le même que toute a l'heure
Oh le batard
Suivant
Ok donc ça c'est le truc qui vole
c'est comme ce que l'on a fait avant
C'est faux! C'est faux! Il se disloque
ouah!!!!! Comment j'ai fais ça?
je suis trop chaud
Ho m*rde
Bon alors, il a pas l'air hyper dur ce boss
Mec le karma il va me fouetter je sais pas pourquoi je fais ça à chaque fois
ouah, c'est encore un nouveau bonbon
puta*n mais ça change tous le temps
puta*n il envoie des billes ?
Non mais lui il est trop dur! Hey tu sais quoi? Hop on va recommencer
hop tu recommences. Quand il est trop dur le premier tu recommence
On va prendre ça et on est bon, c'est parti
Est-ce qu'elle renvoie les mêmes?
ouais c'est ça, c'est les mêmes à chaque fois ok
ouah, le fusil à pompes, c'est tellement puissant
on va pas se mytho, on va rester sur le fusil à pompes
Vas y amène nous ton autre sucrerie
Hey il est un peu chiant lui comme même
Allez, deuxième sucrerie battue
Suivant... Ha non c'est la flaque
faut faire gaffe parce qu'il fait une sorte d'AOE quand il tape le sol vous voyiez
Ho elle sort un fusil la rageuse!
Elle a vue que j'étais trop chaud
Alors c'est quoi ensuite la phase d'après
Elle rage, elle tire les cheveux de ses amis
puta*n c'est quoi... Ho puta*n
ho tabarnak ok là je sens que...C'est quoi ça?
Oh puta*n ( 3x )
j'ai horreur des trucs qui restent
HOOOOOOOO
ho la la je suis trop chaud
Ha ce truc est chiant
Oh il est chiant
On a survécu 15 secondes et regardez où on en est par rapport au drapeau
je pense qu'on va en chier
*musique du jeu*
Ok, chocolat
ok ca y est * rot* dégage
hey je râle, hey *avec une voix + virile que d'habitude*
Ha elle envoie des petits dragibus de m*rde
Ha ça fait longtemps que je l'ai pas vu lui
ho il est ch*ant...
Voila, Jean-Michèle rageuse
Ho lui c'est le plus easy en fait
ho non, puta*n , pourquoi j'ai dit ça en fait? Le karma attention trois deux un
HAAAAAAAA
Ha mais j'ai plus qu'une vie, c'est mort
Alors lui, il est super dur
Papa, tu vas peut etre manger sans moi puta*n
Souvenez vous du sentiment qu'on a eu quand on a gagner le boss d'avant, c'est ça qui fait qu'on va y arriver
Allez, on recommence
* rire*
Allez on vas y arriver, on vas y arriver
* en chantant* Première étape le chocolat
Allez vas t'en, vas t'en t'es mauvais
et voila on en parle plus
qu'est ce qu'il est mauvais
Suivant
Haaa
T'es même pas un bonbon mec, t'es juste un imposteur
Ha batard
HAHA M*RDE
Je sens que ce boss va être extrêmement dur
Et il n'y a plus de batterie
Allez ( x3), on a 20 minutes pour y arriver
Allez là je me sens chaud
HO non je le déteste
Ha j'arrive pas a avoir plus d'une vie pour la fin, c'est terrible ça
Haaaa, j'avais  oublié que j'avais ce pouvoir là
hahaha, exellent
Je sens que celui là, je vais passer la journée dessus
Alors lui, il est nul
Il est venu, il a vu, il a perdu, il a dégagé
Allez suivant.
Ho, lui je le déteste plus que tout
Et voila: N*QUE TA MÈRE
Ha je vais jamais y arriver à celui là
On a deux vies, faut se concentrer
Wow.
Wow?
Ha dommage
Ho !!!
J'en suis qu'à là!
plus que 13 minutes pour réussir à battre ce boss
c'est petit
C'est si dur, c'est si dur
Allez deux vies, on peut le faire
HOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
J'y crois pas! je n'y crois pas
Mais c'est que la troisième fois que j'arrive à aller aussi loin sur cette phase
MAis je vais manger avec mon père et j'aurai battu deux boss
Regarde, on a eu un B, on a même eu une meilleure note
Là je vais annoncer une bonne nouvelle à mon père
* sonnerie* : Oui ?
Ouais, je serai là à midi trente bien à l'heure et je t'inviterai au restaurant
Papa: HOOOOOO bah justement j'entrai dans le métro
j'arrive, j'accours, je vole
Squeezie: exellent
Papa: A tout de suite
Squeezie: A tout
Ho la la, je crois qu'il en avait rien à foutre que je l'invite mais apparemment, il a un peu d'avance
ça va être fantastique de  manger après un victoire pareille
Je vais succuler chauqe bouchées de mon repas
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si elle vous a plu, si vous trouvez que j'ai du skill
J'aimerais voir on est à combien de pourcents du jeu, attendez
MDR
Ha non, MHDR
MH,MDHR pardon
48 pourcents bon bah voila
On a fait un petit treize pourcent du jeu ensemble
ça m'a mis dans tout mes états mais on l'a fait
Merci d'avoir regardé et à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo
Popopo... bon appétit
* outro*